Nagging is the dispiriting, unpleasant, counter-productive
but wholly understandable and poignant version
of a hugely noble ambition: the desire to
change other people. There is so much we might
fairly want to change about them. We’re
an entirely imperfect lot. And so we want
them to be more self-aware, punctual, generous,
reliable, introspective, resilient, communicative,
profound… At home, we want them to focus
more on the sink, the children, the bins,
the money and the need to put the phone down
and look up. At a macro dimension, we want
them to think more about the suffering of
encaged animals, the destruction of our habitat
and the iniquities of capitalism. We are,
most of us, very far from our ideal selves
– and at the level of the species, come
close to an evolutionary error. The desire
to change people is no pathology; it’s a
clear-sighted recognition of human wickedness.
Nagging is, in its essence, an attempt at
teaching, at getting an idea for improvement
from one mind into another. But it is also
a version of teaching that has given up hope.
It has descended into an attempt to insist
rather than invite, to coerce rather than
charm. One has grown too tired, and humiliated
by constant rebuffs to have the energy to
seduce. One is too panicked by the thought
that the unteachable ‘student’ is ruining
one’s life to find the inner resources to
see it a little more from their point of view.
It’s one’s own suffering that dominates
all the available imaginative capacity. And
so one gets straight to the point, gets rid
of the garlands, omits the honey and says
it in plain terms. The bins need attention
now. Get to the table immediately. You’re
a selfish layabout. Not there, here… One
isn’t wrong. One is very right, but also
very tired and, deep down, sad. Lamentably,
also, it doesn’t work. By the time one has
started humiliating the student, the lesson
is over. Nagging breeds its evil twin, shirking.
The other pretends to read the paper, goes
upstairs and feels righteous. The shrillness
of one’s tone gives them all the excuse
they need to trust that we have nothing kind
or true to tell them. One changes others only
when the desire that they evolve has not reached
an insistent pitch, when we can still bear
that they remain as they are. All of us improve
only when we have not been badgered or made
to feel guilty; only when we have a sense
that we are loved and deeply understood for
the many reasons why change is so hard for
us. We know, of course, that the bins need
our attention, that we should strive to get
to bed earlier and that we have been a disappointment
in the couple. But we can’t bear to hear
these lessons in an unsympathetic tone; we
want – tricky children that we are – to
be indulged for our ambivalence about becoming
better people. The same obtuse dynamic is
at play at the political level. We know we
shouldn’t abuse the planet, bend rules or
close our hearts to the unfortunate. But we
won’t do any of the good things if a dour
figure wags their finger and delivers stern
lectures. We want to be charmed, not dragged,
into goodness. The tragedy of nagging is that
its causes are usually so noble – and yet
that it doesn’t work. We nag because we
feel that our possession of the truth lets
us off having to convey it elegantly. It never
does. The solution to nagging isn’t to give
up trying to get others to do what we want.
Rather, it is to recognise that persuasion
always needs to occur in terms that make sense
to those who so badly need to be altered.
We publish new thought provoking films every week.  Be sure to subscribe to our channel
and take a look at more of what we have to offer at the link on your screen now.